high breath there are nine la
psychological laughter triggers okay
nine stimuli that the brain responds to
um
that triggers laughter okay surprise
embarrassment superiority release
configurational
incongruity recognition ambivalence and
uh
and coincidence uh did i get all those
that's about nine
uh sometimes i forget right so then
there are 13
major comedy structures and so uh the
structures pull the triggers
okay so and not every joke just has one
some have multiple once some have ones
where you're like uh well that's kind of
this and this
you know this is comparing contrast and
uh this yeah it can be both
just like you'll have literary uh
scholars arguing over
whether something really fulfills the
obligation of meeting complete irony
you know same thing you know if you uh
you don't have to it's art so and also
you have to remember
as picasso said you got to know the
rules before you can
break the rules it's an art
yes so don't get all wrapped up and it's
got to be this way
you know but a lot of times you can
tweak and go oh if i do make it this way
that joke snaps right and that that's
what
part of comedians trying to just get
away with attitude
they're not learning the rules first
before they break but they just see like
bill burgess up there talking i was like
no he's worked
over half his life at this art form you
know
and he says the first five to seven
years of my career
i did one and two liners because i had
to know how to write a joke
yeah and that's what i did too when you
know how to write a joke when you're on
on the move when you're in the flow
it's easier to see the opportunities or
recognize the opportunities and the
mechanics and the structure
to be able to spin something and go oh i
just put two ids together i'm gonna now
list real quick and put it up there's
the here's the line you know when he
does like go
he's like everybody wants to bang a hot
chick you know
but uh you know the the guy working at
home home depot can't because he's not a
celebrity besides chicks don't dig
lumber
right that's what he says that's his
joke and it's like
all he did was take something from home
depot every time i see the
name somebody says home depot i see a
pallet of two by fours
and he says lumber and boom that
triggers that image
and it makes us laugh what a coincidence
what were the thirteen
thirteen if we go into thirteen we have
double entendre okay uh
incongruity we have uh uh paired phrases
we have simple truth
we have recognition observation so
observation takes the recognition
laughter trigger
and you just basically observe the world
and basically explain what it is
like somebody waiting for a bus they
stand on a curb that's seven inches high
waiting for a bus that's 16 feet tall
and they sit there looking for the bus
they don't see the bus so they step off
the curb leaving
losing seven inches then they raise up
two inches losing a total of five inches
to see a bus that's 16 feet tall
if you can't see it from up there you
can't you're not going to see it from
down there
and all you're doing is taking an
observation and stepping it out for the
audience
so that's obvi and you know comedians
should have a goal of every week
write down five new observations in the
minutia of what's happening in life
and so it's just you set yourself goals
so you're always walking around with
comedic glasses
then you have um then you have
so paraphrases comedic irony paradox
um ambivalence
uh you don't have my list in front of me
and i just got lost
but it's like there's so there's 13 that
you can use
simple truth very simple it's like
double entendre but it's a phrase
that has an intended meaning you find it
a lot in songs we speak in metaphors and
euphemisms and all you're doing as a
comedian
it's all in having your cynicism proving
it wrong
i'm gonna show you that's wrong so
somebody says uh like a song you go to
disneyland
you hear it's a small world have you
listened to the lyrics
it's a world of joy it's a world of
tears it's a world of hope it's a world
of fears
isn't this a song about being bipolar
and honest
the audience goes oh my god never
thought about it the way it's so true
because you're taking that simple truth
and you're flipping it scripture has a
lot of symbolism
if you take that and now go to the
literary simple truth meaning
you can get a joke its essence and its
foundation goes back to call me a cab
you're a cap mm-hmm right so call me a
doctor because is there a doctor and
you know call me a doctor you're a
doctor it's that same raw form
but now expand it out to other things
that we see all the time you know
so uh that's an uh you'll notice that
john stewart people say you want to take
your comedy to the next level
start to recognize comedic irony and um
also a paradox that makes your brain
actually do a dance
paradox is two things that could be true
but not true at the exact same time
for example when carlin used to say on
tv
you could say you pricked your finger
but you can't say you fingered your
prick
it's prick and prick two different
meanings of prick they can be true
for each of their meanings and these but
they can't be true at the exact same
time and oh my god you use them so close
together
you know one they're same word but so
different
so the brain does a little oh wow that's
interesting you know
uh so that's paradox so there's lots of
so many different ways ambivalence
you can build an ambivalent situation
and make sure you have two descriptors
in the in the
in the uh in the sentence
is where specifics are important and
comedians sometimes try to be too
economical
and they remove a potential for joke so
for example if i say my dad
was just diagnosed with stage four colon
cancer
not a lot of opportunity there well
football i did you know i can add that
attitude and maybe
hope for a laugh right but what if i
added more of a descriptor my dad who
lives in bakersfield
was just let's see my dad who lives in
east st louis
just just got diagnosed with stage four
colon cancer
horrible right he lives in east st louis
so we have we're supposed to be
traumatized over the colon cancer but oh
my god he lives in east st
louis you know esther my son who my son
in jersey
just came out of the closet oh oh that's
we you have a son who lives in jersey
right so it's like take using
ambivalence quotient
supposed to be upset about this but
instead i'm upset i'm upset about that
so that extra descriptor helps you get
there you know
that's another technique you can use